I used to love waking up
at exactly 7:00am.
When I lived in San Francisco,
I would wake up right at 7:00am
and immediately go
to my favorite coffee shop.
It was my favorite coffee shop,
because it was the best coffee shop.
I had done the research,
it was five stars, it was great.
And I would drink my coffee
and get onto my bicycle
and ride into work.
And I had optimized
my schedule to be perfect.
I was constantly, like,
shaving off one or two seconds
making it slightly faster
so I could get into work faster.
I was working as a software
engineer at Google,
and in a lot of ways,
this was my dream job.
It felt like this was the thing
that the rest of my life
was leading up towards.
I'd always wanted to work in software
and I was finally doing it.
And I was living in San Francisco,
which is a city that I love,
surrounded by people who were like me.
And every part of my life
was perfectly tailored to my interests,
the things that I wanted to do.
And I loved it.
So one day I was at work
and I started to read this paper,
a computer science research paper
about predictive analytics.
And the gist of the paper was
that if you take someone's GPS trace,
like the listing of all the places
that they've been in the past month or so,
and you feed it into
a machine-learning algorithm,
you can predict with fairly high accuracy
where they're going to be
on the following day.
And I thought this was kind of cool.
And I was thinking, like,
what would happen if you put
my GPS trace into the algorithm?
What would come out the other end?
So I was talking with my friend Kelly,
and we were planning
something to do after work that day.
And I got onto Yelp
and found this really great bar
that had just opened up.
And I was about to suggest
that we go to this bar
when I stopped.
And I started thinking
about that algorithm again.
And I started thinking, wait a second,
isn't this bar exactly where
that algorithm would guess
that I was going to go this evening?
And that was kind of weird.
Because I thought that I ...
where was I in that?
I know that I was the one
making the choice, right?
But how did the computer
know about that?
So that was a little disturbing.
And since I'm an engineer,
whenever I have a problem like this,
my instinct is to fix it,
to make something that solves the problem.
And so I decided to make an app
that would help me choose
where to go on this evening.
And so the way that it works
is that the app looks at all the places
that are on Google maps
in the city of San Francisco,
and then chooses one at random.
And then it calls an Uber.
And that car shows up at your location
and takes you to that random place.
It tells the Uber driver
where the random place is,
but tells you nothing.
And so it's a big surprise
when you arrive.
(Laughter)
And so I texted Kelly and I said,
"We should do this."
We met up and pressed the button.
And suddenly, miraculously,
there was an Uber driver
at my apartment door.
So we got in
and very quickly started heading
to a part of San Francisco
that neither of us really knew.
It was a part of town that we
just had never been in before.
And when the driver told us
we had reached our destination,
we thought it must have been a joke.
We showed up in front
of this austere brick building
with a wrought iron fence in front of it,
and a sign that said the words
San Francisco General Hospital,
Psychiatric Emergency Center.
(Laughter)
Which, maybe that's pretty appropriate,
I don't know.
(Laughter)
But we thought it was funny.
But it was also exhilarating
because here we were,
in this place that we never
would have gone to otherwise,
doing something really different
on a Friday night.
(Laughter)
And I was hooked,
I started using this app
to go to all different places
in San Francisco.
I went to museums randomly,
random grocery stores,
random bars, random bowling alleys,
random florists.
And I started discovering
that there was an entire side
to San Francisco
that I had been ignoring
because of my preference.
And then I started thinking,
how else can I apply
this concept to my life?
And so I started building other
experiments that involved randomness.
I made a random
YouTube video generator,
a random schedule generator,
a random diet club
that would randomly eliminate a food
from my diet each week.
(Laughter)
And it's cumulative,
so eventually you just can't eat.
(Laughter)
Random tattoo generator,
a random Spotify playlist,
random podcast,
a printer that prints out
random suggestions of things to do.
(Laughter)
A random Facebook event generator.
And the way that this one works
is that in a city like Vienna
on a given day,
there are hundreds of Facebook events --
public Facebook events --
that are going on.
So it would choose one at random and say,
this is your plan for tonight.
And so I ended up showing --
(Laughter)
And so I'd show up
at events like Joe's birthday,
the eighth grade band recital,
chess club, truck drivers school.
And it was really interesting
because these were communities
that I knew nothing about
but were having amazing events
to talk about things
that they cared about.
And there I was.
After a while,
I had the opportunity
to transition my work into freelance,
which gave me a lot more flexibility
about where I lived.
And so I decided,
you know, what if I could let
the computer decide
what part of the world I lived in?
And so I wrote a program that figured out
every city that it was possible
for me to live in,
given my budget,
and then chose one at random.
And I started living this way
and it sent me all over the world.
Taipei, Taiwan,
Mumbai, India, Dubai.
Even places that for an American
are really off the beaten path,
like Essen, Germany and Gortina, Slovenia.
And every time I would go to a new city,
I would do the same sort of stuff
I was doing in San Francisco,
go to random events, meet random people.
And I'd live there for two to three months
and then ask the computer again
for the next location.
I did this for two years.
Paradoxically, giving up
control to this machine
actually made me feel more free
than when I was making choices,
because I discovered that ...
My preference had blinded me
from the complexity
and the richness of the world.
And following the computer
gave me the courage
to live outside of my comfort zone,
to discover parts of the human
experience that I ignored
because they were too different
or not for me.
I ended up in Mumbai, India for a while,
and I was going to a lot
of Facebook events when I was there.
And one day, the computer
sent me to this yoga class
and I'm really bad at yoga,
but I went anyway.
I found myself descending
into a downward dog
when I had a revelation.
Because I was thinking about, you know,
this random stuff is really freeing,
it's sort of putting me
outside of my bubble, my comfort zone.
But really how random is it?
Because this was not my first
yoga event in Mumbai.
In fact, it was my third that week.
(Laughter)
And if you think about it,
it's not surprising
that you see patterns like this.
Because I was choosing randomly
from a list of things
that was decidedly not random.
The list of Facebook events
that are happening in a city
is very influenced by the things
that are going on in a city like that.
And if you think about it,
every time you make a choice,
you're not just making it on your own.
You're selecting from a list,
a menu of choices
that was designed
by someone or something else.
And whatever freedom
that you have in that choice
is necessarily constrained
by social structures, customs and history
that provide the context
for that selection.
So initially, I thought of this
as a way of getting outside of my bubble.
As, you know, transcending
myself, my preference.
But eventually I started
to think about it differently.
I started to think about it
as a way of taking a photograph.
When I was in a place like Mumbai,
it was more likely that I would
show up at a yoga event.
But if I was in Vienna,
maybe a music event would be more likely.
Every time that I was choosing
randomly in a city,
what I was doing
was making an inquiry, asking,
"Mumbai, tell me what you're about."
And then the answer would tell me
something about the structure of that city
and my relationship to it
and its relationship
with the rest of the world.
And so I ...
I had, like, a really tidy ending
for this previously.
And as I was coming up here,
I decided to scrap it, because ...
You know, I think that, like,
a problem with TED Talks often
is that they wrap up in a tidy bow
and then you can go away
without really thinking about it.
You can sort of just --
It feels like everything is OK at the end.
And I think ...
In the world that we're living in,
there are a lot of real problems.
And I think that these questions
of algorithmic control
play a lot into them.
We're talking right now about the role
that Facebook had
in the American election.
There are a lot of questions
about the ways that these algorithms
are controlling our lives.
And so, I don't know,
I don't know what I'm saying
and I don't have, like,
a very clear conclusion.
But I would just encourage you
to try to be experimental
when it comes to interacting
with these algorithms.
Because if you just do the defaults,
follow your preference,
go in the direction
that everything else is going,
it's really easy to get caught
in a place where you can be controlled.
And I think that's it.
Thank you.
(Applause)